I am garry kasparov here at chess club
and scholastic center of san luis and we
are about to watch a great event
showdown in st. Louis were four players
Nakamura Khurana who you fun and Negi
will play classic rapid blitz and of
course this random of course it's random
of course we know it's it could have 960
variations we had an idea actually was
my old dream to engage the public you to
be part of this event by voting on
Twitter for the position that you like
to play in the specific games but before
you do that I'm here to make suggestions
my first suggestion is very very simple
I don't know whether we can call random
it's to replace bishops and knights in
the original positions so to have two
bishops on the nightspots and vice versa
here is the second position that's
already non-traditional you'll have
bishops in in the corner on the Queen
side and then you have rooks on the
kingside looking for different positions
I always try to make sure that the pawns
are protected I mean just you don't have
terrible witnesses that could create
huge discomfort for a player so position
number three as you see all the pawns
are protected and I have to tell you I
don't know how just you make the best
move so I guess and it takes time to
understand you know how you will develop
the pieces because the moment you move
any of these pawns so there will be
unprotected so yeah I wonder you know
how this position
at one point we have to move white thing
to the inside so now it's on c1 and you
have to think of the bishops for stanky
toes
so maybe it gives an advantage for those
who play Kingston and groom no idea but
very you know interesting to find out so
how this thing get the bishops will
enter the basil without any illegally
and invading each other
position number five very solid I could
sense you know that's the potentially
good coordination of the pieces but
still it's it's interesting to you
understand what's the what will be the
ideal first move so proof push this poem
to open the bishop open the rook because
I could see also many potentially weak
squares and I wonder how the plate will
will deal with this these balance of
witnesses position number six it's more
of the traditional fish random because
it's very chaotic and I'm sure those who
play this this kind of [ __ ] before I
mean they'll they will know how to deal
with this I'm not very comfortable with
this configuration but you know at one
point you you should throw into you into
the loop position that is not there
Orthodox now after the extremes we go
back to what you may call normal in
Fischer random so at least you have King
and and and Queen in there just original
positions you have at least one night on
here on b1 and other pieces they are
it's a they're not on their positions
original positions but I could feel that
there's enough harmony and now back to
almost normal classical chess so the
five pieces on the original positions
you know you have you know Group Knight
Bishop
queen and king and reshuffling just on
one side of the board I think it's quite
significant of course but naturally it
brings this game as close to normal as
possible though I am I'm still wondering
whether they even did minor change
rather than minor change as this one
could still read the game into uncharted
waters but we'll find out
you will make a choice you can watch
this game slide on us chess champs calm
but before it happens
you can vote on Twitter and decide how
these great players will start their
games thanks for participating in this
event and enjoy the show